our next speaker is eric van epps and
eric has given us the title
interventions for healthy eating
evidence from field experiments so I'm a
behavioral economist and I study how to
help people make healthier decisions in
my dissertation I focus specifically on
how to help people make healthier eating
decisions following from many public
policy interventions aimed at reducing
obesity rates now when we think about
the behavioural economics toolkit what
tools can we come to bring to bear on
public policy there's three main tools
that we generally have choice
architecture or changing the structure
of the decision itself information
provision and incentives now incentives
can be expensive and difficult to
maintain over time so in our research we
focus on the first two choice
architecture and information provision
and we apply these approaches to try to
help people make healthier eating
decisions we do this by recruiting
participants there are full-time
employees of a real corporation in the
workplace setting to place their actual
lunch orders from an online ordering
system that we developed in
collaboration with an on-site corporate
cafeteria by using this online ordering
system we can isolate and manipulate
factors involved in the ordering
experience and identify the the impact
that those manipulations have on
people's ordering decisions great so in
the first study we looked at choice
architecture and we specifically looked
at the time at which people place their
orders this follows from some
theoretical work suggesting that people
make healthier decisions when placing
orders in advance and sure enough we do
find that when we randomly assign people
to place their orders in advance those
people who order in advance are more
likely to think that their orders are
healthier and they're more likely to
choose items that are identified as
low-calorie items however there's no
difference between advanced ordering and
lunchtime ordering in terms of the
actual calorie contents and nutrient
content of their meals that is that
although there are behavioral and
perceptual changes in response to
advanced ordering there's no clinically
meaningful difference in health outcomes
which is what we really care about so in
study 2 we turn our attention to
information provision and we do this by
randomly assigning people to see
different kinds of menus when they log
into our system on these menus there's
labels identifying the calorie content
of each item on the menu
these can be numeric labels traffic
light labels a combination of the two or
in a control condition no labels laws
passed in places like New York City and
King County Washington have tested the
effect of these numeric calorie labels
and they found little to no effect of
these numeric labels on people's calorie
consumption but by moving into the
online ordering context we can actually
isolate the impact of information
provision on people's ordering decisions
getting rid of a lot of the visceral and
social factors that might influence
people's decisions in a fast food
ordering environment what we find is
that each type of label whether a
numeric traffic light labeling or a
combination of the two leads to a 60 to
70 calorie reduction in people's orders
which is a promising sign for
policymakers to be sure more remains to
be done to best identify the strategies
that will help people reduce calories in
their lunch orders what we've done in
the present work is identify a possible
limitation of a choice architecture
approach a possible Avenue for
information provision and we believe
that continuing to integrate these
approaches with other creative
approaches will help to stem the obesity
epidemic in America thank you for your
time